en este vídeo veremos como determinar si
una reacción se lleva a cabo mediante un
mecanismo sn 1 o sn 2 y también veremos
cómo dibujar el producto o los productos
para esas reacciones y como apoyo
usaremos este resumen entonces lo
primero que analizaremos es la
estructura de nuestro sustrato por
ejemplo para esta reacción tenemos un
alumno de alquilo primario un sustrato
primario así que necesitamos pensar en
un mecanismo sn 2 porque necesitamos
poco impedimento estético y eso es lo
que tenemos con un alumno de alquilo
primario ahora por un vídeo anterior
sabemos que en un mecanismo sn dos
ocurre un ataque núcleo físico al mismo
tiempo que se va el grupo saliente y
para esta reacción nuestro núcleo filo
tiene que ser nuestro solvente que en
este caso es el etanol entonces el
oxígeno formará un enlace con este
carbón que lo voy a resaltar de color
rojo
entonces el núcleo filo ataca al electro
filo al mismo tiempo que se va el grupo
saliente así que estos electrones se van
junto con el yodo para formar el año en
yoduro que es un excelente grupo
saliente entonces dibujemos lo que se
forma primero dibujemos la cadena de
carbonos y sabemos que se forma un
enlace entre el oxígeno y el carbono de
color rojo así que el carbono rojo es
este carbono y vamos a poner estos
electrones de color rosa entonces esos
electrones forman un enlace entre el
oxígeno y el carbono rojo y el oxígeno
aún está unido a este grupo de tilo
vamos a dibujarlo aquí y también está
unido a este hidrógeno vamos a ponerlo
por acá y aún tenemos un par de
electrones libres en este oxígeno ok y
todo esto le da al oxígeno una carga
formal positiva pero necesitamos tener
una molécula neutra como producto
qué otra molécula de etanol entra porque
recuerden que el etanol es nuestro
solvente y esta vez la molécula de
etanol funcionará como una base entonces
necesitamos tomar este protón para dejar
estos electrones en el oxígeno dibujemos
el producto final aquí tenemos la cadena
de carbonos después tenemos el oxígeno
después tenemos estos dos carbonos y
ahora tenemos dos pares de electrones
libres en el oxígeno voy a resaltar
estos electrones de color azul entonces
el segundo paso es una reacción ácido
base tomamos un protón y así los
electrones de color azul
nos quedan aquí así formamos nuestro
producto final que en este caso es un
éter y observen que no tenemos que
preocuparnos por la stereo química en
este producto porque no tenemos ningún
centro gira
veamos otra reacción en este caso
empezamos con un alumno de alquilo
secundario y si observamos el resumen
podemos ver que para un sustrato
secundario puede ocurrir el mecanismo sn
2 o el sn 1 pero necesitamos tomar en
cuenta un par de cosas primero veamos el
núcleo filo
aquí tenemos n a más y sh menos entonces
dibujemos el sh menos por aquí
este es nuestro núcleo filo es un núcleo
filo fuerte porque tenemos una carga
formal negativa en el azufre ok y cómo
nuestro solvente en un vídeo anterior
vimos que el dms o es un solvente polar
a práctico lo que favorece a una
reacción s n 2 así que con un núcleo
filo fuerte y un solvente polar a
práctico necesitamos pensar en un
mecanismo sn 2 entonces sabemos que
nuestro núcleo filo ataca al mismo
tiempo que perdemos el grupo saliente el
núcleo filo attack
a este carbono que lo voy a resaltar de
color rojo y al mismo tiempo nos
deshacemos del grupo saliente estos
electrones se van junto con el bromo
para formar el a nyon bromuro y en esta
reacción sn 2 si necesitamos pensar en
la estéreo química así que nuestro
núcleo filo tiene que atacar del lado
opuesto al grupo saliente por lo que
ocurre la inversión de la configuración
entonces si tenemos un centro quiral
necesitamos preocuparnos por la estéreo
química en este caso tenemos al bromo
representado con una cuña así que al
dibujar nuestro producto final el sh nos
queda lejos de nosotros y lo
representamos con una línea punteada
ocurre la inversión de la configuración
en esta reacción es n 2
ahora analicemos este alumno de alquilo
el carbono que está unido al bromo
también está unido a otros 2 carbonos
así que este es un alumno de alquilo
secundario por lo tanto puede ocurrir
una reacción mediante un mecanismo sn 1
o sn 2 pero necesitamos tomar en cuenta
al núcleo filo y al solvente para
decidir cual en este caso el núcleo filo
es el ácido fórmico que es un núcleo
filo débil y el agua es un solvente
polar pro tico y sabemos que estas dos
cosas favorecen al mecanismo sn 1 porque
el agua al ser un solvente polar
práctico puede estabilizar el carbó
catión que obtendremos entonces el
primer paso es la pérdida del grupo
saliente con lo que se forma el carbó
catión estos electrones se van junto con
el bromo para formar el año en bromuro y
como le quitamos un enlace a este
carbono de color rojo ahora tendrá una
carga formal positiva vamos a dibujar
aquí tenemos el anillo
con sus electrones pi y este es el
carbono rojo que ahora tiene una carga
formal positiva y ahora voy a resaltar
este carbono este carbono de color rosa
corresponde a este carbono pero lo he
puesto así para que sea más fácil ver el
mecanismo entonces este es nuestro carbó
catión secundario y además es un carbó
catión bencílico que lo hace aún más
estable porque los electrones pide el
anillo ayudan a generar otras
estructuras de resonancia para
estabilizar la carga positiva ahorita no
nos da tiempo de demostrarlo pero lo más
importante es que sepan que tenemos un
carbó catión secundario que además es un
carbó catión bencílico ese es nuestro
electro filo y en el siguiente paso el
núcleo filo ataca al electro filo
entonces en este caso el núcleo filo es
el ácido fórmico y observen que tenemos
dos oxígenos aquí uno de ellos es más
núcleo físico que el otro y resulta que
y este oxígeno en el carbón y lo es más
núcleo físico que este oxígeno
entonces si nuestro núcleo fi lo ataca
al electro filo un par de electrones
libres en este oxígeno forman un enlace
con el carbono de color rojo entonces
dibujemos el resultado de ese ataque
núcleo físico aquí tenemos nuestro
anillo y el carbono rojo es este carbono
vamos a resaltar los electrones en el
oxígeno este par de electrones libres de
color azul formaron un enlace con el
carbono rojo entonces aquí tenemos al
oxígeno que aún tiene un par de
electrones libres y este oxígeno está
unido con un doble enlace a un carbono
que a su vez está unido a un hidrógeno y
del lado derecho tenemos el otro oxígeno
y un hidrógeno ok y ahora tenemos una
carga formal positiva en este oxígeno y
este producto es estabilizado por
resonancia
y que podemos mover uno de estos pares
de electrones libres hacia acá con lo
que estos electrones se mueven hacia el
oxígeno
entonces dibujemos lo que nos queda
pondré los corchetes
ok aquí tenemos nuestro anillo
después tenemos los carbonos después
tenemos un enlace con este oxígeno que
ya tenía un par de electrones libres y
ahora solo tenemos un enlace con este
carbono y por acá tenemos el hidrógeno y
ahora tenemos un doble enlace por aquí
ok
déjenme resaltar el movimiento de
electrones primero empecemos con estos
electrones de color rosa estos
electrones se movieron para formar el
doble enlace y estos electrones de color
rojo se movieron al oxígeno por lo que
ahora tenemos una carga formal positiva
en este oxígeno entonces el producto del
ataque núcleo físico por el oxígeno del
carbón y lo es estabilizado por
resonancia y para llegar al producto
final digamos que una base como por
ejemplo el agua entra y toma este protón
con lo que estos electrones se quedan en
el oxígeno dibujemos el producto aquí
tenemos el anillo por aquí tenemos un ok
sí
que no y después tenemos el carbón hilo
y un hidrógeno entonces este oxígeno
tiene dos pares de electrones libres al
igual que este oxígeno y para resaltar
los electrones supongamos que estos
electrones de color verde se quedaron en
este oxígeno
este es nuestro producto ahora observen
que aquí tenemos un centro que irá miren
este carbono es un centro quiral porque
tenemos cuatro grupos diferentes unidos
a ese carbono así que esperaríamos
obtener una mezcla race mica de
productos es decir esperamos obtener los
2 enantiómero porque si regresamos a
nuestro carbó catión este kart vocación
tiene una geometría plana así que el
núcleo filo puede atacar por los dos
lados si se preguntan por qué este
oxígeno no está núcleo físico como el
oxígeno en el carbón y lo les mostraré
lo que pasaría si este oxígeno ataca al
carbono cargado positivamente entonces
vamos
dibujar el anillo ahí está y ahora
formamos un enlace entre el oxígeno y el
carbono rojo que sería este carbono
entonces este par de electrones libres
forman un enlace con ese carbono y está
unido a este oxígeno que a su vez está
unido al grupo carbón hilo y aquí
tenemos un hidrógeno ok y este oxígeno
aún está unido a un hidrógeno y aún
tiene un par de electrones libres
entonces aquí tenemos el hidrógeno y el
par de electrones libres y todo eso le
da al oxígeno una carga formal positiva
ahora observen que este oxígeno cargado
positivamente se encuentra junto a este
carbono en el carbón y lo y sabemos que
este carbono tiene una carga parcial
positiva porque este oxígeno retira un
poco de densidad electrónica entonces
aquí tenemos un oxígeno cargado
positivamente junto a un carbono
positivo y sabemos qué cargas iguales se
repelen así que al tener estas dos
cargas positivas tan cerca
desestabilizamos la estructura por eso
es que este oxígeno no es el núcleo filo
sino el oxígeno en el carbón y lo veamos
un último ejemplo aquí tenemos una luro
de alquilo terciario y un sustrato
terciario nos habla de un mecanismo sn 1
entonces el primer paso es la pérdida
del grupo saliente estos electrones se
van junto con el yodo para formar el año
en yoduro con lo que le quitamos un
enlace a este carbono de color rojo para
formar un kart vocación haré más espacio
ok
dibujemos nuestro cargo khatib aquí
tenemos nuestro anillo de 6 miembros y
nuestro carbono rojo es este carbono y
ese carbono tiene una carga formal
positiva así que obtenemos un carbó
catión terciario que es relativamente
estable y en el siguiente paso el núcleo
fi lo ataca
electro filo en este caso el núcleo filo
es el solvente el metanol entonces el
núcleo filo ataca al electro filo el
oxígeno forma un enlace con el carbono
rojo dibujemos el resultado de ese
ataque núcleo físico aquí tenemos el
anillo después tenemos el metil y ahora
hemos formado un enlace con este oxígeno
entonces este es el carbono rojo y estos
electrones de color rosa formaron este
enlace entre el oxígeno y el carbono
rojo y el oxígeno aún está unido a un
hidrógeno y a un grupo metilo entonces
aquí tenemos el hidrógeno y por acá
tenemos el grupo metilo y aún tenemos un
par de electrones libres en el oxígeno y
todo eso le da al oxígeno una carga
formal positiva ok y para el producto
final necesitamos tener un producto
neutro entonces otra molécula de metano
le entra pero esta vez en lugar de
actuar
como un núcleo filo funcionará como una
base y tomara el protón entonces esta es
nuestra molécula de metanol y vamos a
tomar este protón dejando estos
electrones en el oxígeno dibujemos
nuestro producto aquí tenemos el anillo
después tenemos el grupo metilo y por
acá tenemos al oxígeno que está unido a
un grupo metilo y ahora tenemos dos
pares de electrones libres en el oxígeno
entonces estos electrones en azul se
quedaron en el oxígeno para formar el
producto final y observen que nuestro
producto final no tenemos ningún centro
quiral así que no necesitamos
preocuparnos por la estéreo química